Today I want to discuss how this war
will end. I cannot predict when this war
will end but I want to make certain
predictions about how
uh this war will end. Okay. So to first
understand how the war is going, let's
look at some um video clips. All right.
So this is President Donald Trump. is
talking about the war
>> hit Qatar, Saudi Arabia, UAE, Bahrain,
Kuwait. Nobody expected that. We were
shocked. And the other one, you know,
they fought back. They could have
yielded. But think of it, if we weren't
around, they have tremendous They had
tremendous power. They had thousands of
missiles, most of which we've
terminated.
They had thousands of drones. They were
making drones and missiles all over the
place. We've knocked out most of those
factories. They hit.
>> Okay. So, what he's saying here is we
went in expecting them expecting to hit
them, kill the leadership, and then they
would surrender. We didn't expect them
to fight back. We didn't expect them to
close the whole moves. We didn't expect
that they would hit Qatar, Bahrain,
Kuwait. Okay. So what he's saying is we
actually have a plan going in and we
really didn't think our enemies would
fight back. All right. So that this is
Donald Trump.
Now let's look at um
his
president's preference is always peace.
There does not need to be any more death
and destruction. But if Iran fails to
accept the reality of the current moment
if they fail to understand that they
have been defeated militarily and will
continue to be, President Trump will
ensure they are hit harder than they
have ever been hit before. President
Trump does not bluff and he is prepared
to unleash hell.
Okay. So, what she This is Karen Levit
and she's the press secretary for the
White House. And what she's saying is,
"Look, we've defeated these guys, but
for whatever reason, the Iranians don't
know that."
That's the problem. The problem isn't
us. We came in with the right strategy.
We did everything right. But for
whatever reason, the Iranians being
stupid
don't know they've been defeated.
All right.
Never in history has a modern military
Iran had a modern military, a modern
navy, a modern air force, modern air
defenses, leadership, massive bunker.
Never has a modern military been so
rapidly and historically obliterated,
defeated from day one with overwhelming
firepower. The air campaign that we've
conducted, that Israel's conducted
alongside us, was one for the history
books truly. And it's because we have a
president of the United States that when
he sends his war fighters out to fight,
he unties their hands to actually go out
and close with and destroy the enemy as
viciously as possible from moment one.
And that's why we see ourselves as part
of this negotiation as well. Uh we're we
we negotiate uh with bombs. You have a
choice as we loiter over the top of
Tyrron as the president talked about
about your future. President has made it
clear that you will not have a nuclear
weapon. The War Department agrees our
job is to ensure that and so we're
keeping our our hand on that throttle uh
as long as as hard as is necessary to
ensure the interests of the United
States of America are achieved on.
>> Okay. So this is secretary of war Peter
Hexv and he represents the Pentagon, the
military and his attitude is we're
winning this war. We are kicking ass and
we don't have to negotiate because we're
kicking ass and we'll continue to do so.
All right. So this is the attitude of
the military. Now um the US media has
been reporting that Donald Trump is
seeking an offramp. He's seeking
negotiations.
And what Peter Hex says, "No, let's
negotiate with bombs, man." Okay
across the administration and at
Treasury, we unsanctioned Russian oil.
We knew that there were about 130
million barrels on the water and we
created supply that is beyond the
straits of Hermouth. So we anticipated
this. We knew that the there could be a
temporary and I want to emphasize
temporary choke point there and there
was 130 million barrels of floating
storage in the coming days. uh we may
unsanction the Iranian oil that's on the
water. It's about 140 million barrels.
So depending on how you count it, that's
10 days to two weeks of supply that the
Iranians had been pushing out. That
would have all gone to China. In
essence, we will be using the Iranian
barrels against the Iranians to keep the
price down, you know, for the next 10 or
14 days.
>> Okay. So this is the secret secretary of
the treasury Scott Bessett. Okay. And
he's responding to a problem which is um
the Americans didn't expect that the
Iranians would close off the shareholds
and so this is affecting oil supply
and so the global economy could be
disrupted or even destroyed if this
lasts too long. So Scott Besson says,
"Ha, we knew this was going to happen
and we have a really brilliant plan to
destroy the Iranians once and for all."
Our plan is this. We're going to let the
Iranians sell their oil and MAKE A LOT
OF money
and then they'll be destroyed. Yeah. So
um the Americans basically unsanctioned
Iranian oil and because of that the
Iranians were were able to make $14
billion just like that. The total
Iranian military budget for one year is
$10 billion.
Okay. So this is American genius at
work. They knew this was was happen.
They knew the Iranians wanted to destroy
the global economy. So the Americans
like, "What to make them rich so they
can't destroy the global economy?" We
got them now.
All right.
And yet Iran remains a threat. a threat
to trade, a threat to the to the straits
of Harmuth, then I would argue that we
could have years years of, you know,
above $100, closer to $150 oil.
>> What happens to the global economy? If
that happens, how do we see it?
>> We'll have global recession. If there's
a sessation of war and yet Iran,
>> okay, so this is Larry Frink and he's
head of a company called Black Rockck,
which is the largest asset manager in
the world. They control trillions and
trillions of dollars. And what he's
saying he's he's being interviewed by
the BBC. What he's saying is we can't
stop this war now because
if we stop this war now that means that
the price of oil will be too high for
many many years. The Iranians will
control the shoo and therefore we must
fight this war to the end. What he
doesn't address is well if you didn't
start this war in the first place you
wouldn't have this problem because the
Iranians would would have no pretext to
close off the trip of humus and the glob
would have been fine but what he's
saying that but what he's saying is like
oh don't worry about that uh but problem
is like is the war has started and
therefore we must fight to the end Okay.
Okay, so this is a drone launched by a
Iranian proxy in Iraq flying over an
American base.
And as you can see, there's nothing
stopping it. Okay, it's just flying over
this American base. It's it's being
remote controlled. It spots two American
helicopters and destroys one of them.
Okay, meaning that you have all these
American bases throughout the Middle
East and they are vulnerable. They
cannot be protected against cheap
drones.
So from American perspective, this war
will either bankrupt the the Americans
or this war will be lost. Okay? But it's
very hard to fight this war against a
determined enemy. So what I want to do
now is
examine how this war will turn out.
Okay. So um I've said this many times
but the Americans are losing this war
and the main reason is the problem of
hubris.
And so I want to examine closely what
this means strategically what this means
on the battlefield. Okay. So war is
fought across
four dimensions.
All right. There is the narrative
dimension, meaning global opinion, how
history will perceive this war. There is
the political dimension,
meaning
how your allies
perceive this war, how your domestic
base perceive this war. There's the
economic,
and then there's the military.
If you if we examine this war closely,
the Iranians are fighting a very
different war
from the Americans.
What the Americans are doing is
basically they are shifting the
narrative, political sphere and economic
sphere to fit their economic strategy.
Okay. Their regular strategy is
decapitation
which forces surrender. Right. So what
they want to do is they want to not
destroy the Iranian leadership, destroy
the Iranian economy to force a surrender
in which case the Americans can dictate
terms. That is their strategy and that's
about it. and they are forcing the
narrative space, the political space and
the economic space to conform to the
military strategy. Meaning that they
expect the allies NATO, they expect the
media, they expect uh the economy to
support their strategy. So for example
um in the political space Donald Trump
has ordered NATO to come and open up the
strip of humus. Okay. And also Donald
Trump refuses to acknowledge the fact
that this war is very unpopular back in
America. In the economic space what the
Americans are trying to do is keep the
price of oil low so it does not just
swap the global economy. And they do
that of course by unsectioning Russian
and Iranian oil which benefits the
Russian and Iranian economies. Okay. And
in a nar in a narrow space they're
basically trying to tell the media to
follow the party line. Donald Trump has
threatened journalists that if you do
not report this war is going well then I
might put you in prison. All right. So
this is the American strategy forcing
the narrative, political and and
economic spirits to conform to military
strategy. The Iranians have a different
approach. The Iranians are using the
military in order to impact the
economic, political and narrative
spheres. All right, it's complete
reverse. Um so the military strategy is
calibrated in a certain way to
um benefit the Iranian economy. Okay. So
what I mean by that is
that the military is strategically
controlling the surgical moves so that
Chinese ships can pass, right? Because
Chinese ships are the main buyer of
Iranian oil. Also, if you are um if
you're willing to play ball like Japan
or Qatar or Oman, they will also let
your ships pass. Okay,
so this is being strategic. Politically,
um the Iranians are trying to split the
Gulf States, right? They know that Saudi
Arabia and UAE are committed to regime
change in Iran, but they know that
Qatar, BN, sorry, sorry, not B, Qatar
and Oman are on the other side. Okay.
So, so they're trying to gain as much
global leverage as possible within the
GCC. And the narrative is they're trying
to shape global opinion and trying to um
make everyone believe that they are are
on the right side of history. And most
people believe that. In fact, you have a
lot of Americans who are rooting for the
Iranians to win. All right. So, this is
a very different these are two um very
different strategies. All right. So,
let's talk about this the advantages and
disadvantages of both strategies. Okay.
So from the Merlin perspective,
the fact that you have this have this
approach of making the world conform to
your military strategy basically means
that you lack what we call reflection.
Okay?
Meaning that you're not able to sit down
with your strategist and discuss how how
this war is going and how to make
changes. But the Iranians are able to do
so because the military has to conform
to the economic, political and narrative
strategies. Okay.
Second is
flexibility. And what I mean by that is
the military strategy. If it's not going
well for the Americans, they lack the
capacity to reflect and make changes. So
what they do is they double down. Okay?
to accelerate the process of bombing in
Iraq even though it's probably not going
getting them anywhere. Also, much more
importantly, the Americans will choose
much more self-destructive desperate
strategies such as sending ground
troops. It is possible by this weekend
ground troops will be sent into Iran
which most military analysts believe to
be u either counteractive or suicidal.
Okay. The um Iranians on the other hand
can adapt their milit military strategy
to the economic and political realities.
Okay. So for example, what they're doing
now is they're charging tolls um to
cross the shoo. Okay. And the third
difference is the idea of resilience.
So in other words, if you make the world
and America conform to your military
strategy, they won't support you. That
means that if you're losing troops
and you're losing equipment, it is very
hard to replenish,
resupply.
Whereas the complete opposite in Iran
where because they are winning popular
opinion because their economy is
becoming stronger in this process
because they're winning more political
allies they can actually draw on more
support from a population and they can
also recruit foreign fighters and
foreign support foreign sympathy for
their cause. Okay. So for these reasons,
I believe that America is losing this
war and that ultimately this war will be
lost.
When this will happen, we don't know
because America is an empire and they
can they can actually drag us on for at
least 20 years. All right. Okay. So now
that we've discussed why America will
probably lose this war, I want to now
shift our focus to discuss
how the world will change because of
this war. What does the end of this war
look like? And to do that, what's really
important is to go back to our model of
how the world works. Okay? So remember
last week we discussed um the structure
of the world and at the very core is the
empire
because the empire provides the muscle
the military might to shape the contours
of reality. Okay. And then with the
empire you have the f the finance. Okay.
finance includes
um city of London, Wall Street, Bang of
National Settlements
and asset managers and they are the game
masters. Okay.
Okay. The empire is the muscle but the
finance are the ones who actually set
the game
and then this creates the global economy
which is based on the US dollar right
but you can't actually
have people believing that this is the
way the game is structured because then
people won't want to play the game so
what you do is you create additional
layer of multilateral organizations what
the Americans like to call the
rulesbased international order including
the UN and the WTO, okay, and other
organizations. But this is but this
makes people believe
that um the way the world is structured
is fair, open and transparent and you
hide the finance and the empire behind
multilateral organizations. Okay. And
then to justify
um this system you have the uh culture,
education
and media which then creates the
different legal infrastructure of
different nations and the values as
well. Okay. So this is how the world is
organized. We also discuss how there are
these organizations that are above the
nation state that are above the system
in order to benefit from the system to
keep it going but also to extract rent
from it. And these include
um intelligence,
crime
and science. We also discussed how the
organizing
u forces behind intelligence, crime and
science um are transnational capital
uh secret societies
as well as elite families
and we discuss how they are bound
together by a concept called the occult
which we'll study later on. Okay, but
the idea of the occult. Okay. So this is
the structure of the world. Now once
this world is created what you need to
understand is that the people in the
different spheres who benefit from the
system first and foremost their interest
is maintaining that status quo. Okay. So
their interest is in maintaining the
status quo.
All right. So basically they want the
system to continue.
The problem with the system is at the
core is an empire that will probably
lose the war in Iran. And this creates a
problem because if the empire falls then
it's possible that this entire edifice
falls as well. So the only solution is
to replace the empire, the American
empire with another empire. All right,
that is able to provide the muscle for
this system. And this empire I've argued
in the past is of course Israel.
And this what we call past Judea.
Okay. So on the surface it seems like
this war is one between the United
States and Iran. But in reality what
this war really is about is a war
between the United States and Israel
where the American Empire has become
corrupt, incompetent and arrogant. And
so now Israel sees an opportunity to
replace the American empire in the
system. And this is something that
eventually every aspect of the system
will agree to do. All right. So the main
outcome of this war when it ends is that
Israel will replace America in the
Middle East. Okay. All right.
So let me first discuss
why the American empire is falling.
Okay. And the main reason is the idea of
something called the military
industrial
complex.
So
for most of its history, America did not
have a professional army. Why? Because
the founding fathers and most American
citizens believe that if there's if
there's an standing army if there's
professional army that's a direct threat
to the liberty
of the Americans. Okay? Because the
Americans fought a war the revolutionary
war to get rid of of the professional
army that was the British. Okay? So
Americans do not like a professional
army. But in order to fight World War I
and World War II, they didn't have a
choice but to create a standing army.
The problem is that after America won
World War II, the apparatus stayed and
the apparatus wanted to maintain the
status quo, meaning they wanted access
to unlimited government funds. So this
led to the cold war and the cold war was
a justification
for the MIC, the military-industrial
complex
to get as much government funding as
possible. And the blue, as you can see,
is government expenditures. Okay, we can
understand why they spent all this money
in World War II because they were
fighting a war to save America and to
save the world. But as you can see, uh,
even though it dropped drastically at
the end of the war, starting with the
cold war, you have this uptick. Okay?
And then you have the Vietnam War. And
then um, after America won the cold war,
you saw this massive uptick. This
something called the war on terror.
So the industrial complex is always
looking to start wars.
in order to justify its existence. So
there's a very famous journalist named
Julian Assange
and he said this about America. The
point is not to have successful wars.
The point is not to win wars. The point
is to have neverending wars which allows
the military-industrial complex to
transfer American taxpayer money
to a transnational elite. Okay. It's
basically the point of wars is for the
military-industrial complex to steal as
much money as possible from America.
Okay.
Um, America spends a lot of money
uh in its military. Okay. America
accounts for 41%
of all global military spending. Um,
who's next? China. China spends 8.2%.
Uh, Russia, which is America's main
military enemy, only spends 4.1%.
Okay? Meaning that Russia spends
onetenth the amount of money that
America spends.
And you think that, okay, well, this all
this means that is that America is
invincible. But what people don't
recognize is the level of corruption
within the American military. The
American military is probably the most
corrupt institution in the world by far.
No one even comes close. Okay. Um
September 10th,
uh 2001,
Donald Rumsfield, who's the secretary of
defense for the Americans, uh he's head
of the Pentagon, and this is a day
before September 11th, the 911 attacks.
He said that he he had a press
conference and he said that look, we've
looked at the Pentagon books. Okay,
we're trying to do an accounting of the
Pentagon military uh spending and we
can't find $2 trillion. There's $2
trillion missing from the budget. It
went somewhere. We don't know where, but
it went somewhere. Okay. All right. All
right. So, this is a um So, where does
the money go? It goes to private
contractors. Okay. These are all private
companies
that
make a lot of money off the government.
Okay, so look at look at the Boeing
company.
They had in one year
20 billion
um
from the government. They they got $20
billion in contracts from the
government. Okay. To do so, they had to
send $16 million
in order to lobby Congress through
advertisements, through political
campaigns. And then they bribed this.
This is a bribe to politicians. They
they spent $2 million. Okay.
So, this is a really good business to be
in. you spend $2 million
uh to you you you give them rods to
politicians, then you spend $16 million
um on campaigns and then you make $20
billion. Okay, this is extremely
profitable. The difference of course is
being picked up by the American
taxpayer.
The boy company is um doesn't is not
just a defense contractor but also makes
civilian airplanes. And for these past
few years, there's been quite a few
cases of civilian airplanes falling out
of the sky made by Boeing. Okay, so for
example, the Boeing 737 Max. Okay, there
was a recall because there were some
engineering issues with the plane. Now,
there have been a couple of
whistleblowers who've come out and tried
to say that Boeing uh is a very cool
company and for the reason they they
died. Okay, they just disappear. We
don't know why, but when they were about
to testify against Boeing, they somehow
died. All right. Um, this is a really
interesting story that shows you the
level of corruption in the Pentagon.
There is this woman who's a contractor
for the army and she stole $103 million.
Okay, that's a lot of money. $103
million. She stole it. The army didn't
know. and she kept on stealing and no
one seemed to care in the army.
But then the IRS
um this is the Internal Revenue Service.
They recognized that she was getting all
this money from somewhere. So they
investigated her and recognized, "Oh my
god, she's stealing from the army." So
the IRS told the army and that's when
the army recognized, "Oh, we have a
problem." Okay.
The fact that the army didn't notice
that she was stealing $13 million tells
you actually theft in the military is
probably a very common thing. All right.
So ultimately what this means is
that this corruption in the Pentagon is
not really sustainable. Okay. So let me
discuss
um
why this is a problem for America in
Iran. Okay. So right now America is
facing three major issues
um with this war in Iran.
Uh the first major issue is the lack of
political will.
meaning that this war is very unpopular
in America. Only 40% of the population
currently support this war. And as
things go on and on, support will
probably decrease. Okay. Um, you need
political will because you need
Americans to pay for this war. Trump has
asked for $200 billion to fund this war.
And also, it's possible that Trump will
call the national draft, which I believe
will happen. Um, okay. So if Americans
don't want to support this war, it's
very hard to get them to pay for this
war and to go fight this war. Second
problem is lack of manufacturing
capacity.
So in other words, what this means is
that if you lose planes, if you spend
too many uh if you use too many bombs,
you cannot replenish it because you
don't have the factories to produce
these planes and uh bombs quickly
enough. Okay?
And so if this war drags on too uh long,
then America will just run out of bombs.
And the and the uh third problem for
America is unwillingness
to sustain
casualties. Okay? And what this means is
that Americans, the American military is
afraid of reporting deaths, casualties,
which is weird because in a war soldiers
die. That's just the reality of war. But
the Pentagon is afraid of reporting too
many deaths because of the back because
of the fair political backlash.
Okay. So these are three major problems
for the American military in Iran. These
are the three major uh constraints.
All right. So the Americans can't
actually resolve these issues. America
will probably lose this war. In which
case this gives opportunity for Israel
to prove
to the world that it should be the
empire. Okay. And it it proves it can be
the empire by showing that it does have
polical will. It does have a it does
have it doesn't have the manufacturing
capacity but has more sod. Okay. And it
is much more uh strategic.
The last thing is that it is resilient
meaning that it is willing to accept
casualties. Okay. So basically the idea
here is the global elite they need an
empire to provide the muscle but the
empire must prove that it can serve the
needs of the global elite. Okay? And it
and so an empire must prove three
things. First of all, it must prove
um
uh
unity.
It must prove um it has the resources
and the capacity
basically the capacity. Okay.
And it must prove
um determination,
right?
So to understand this idea, let's just
do a thought experiment, right? Let's
just say that we're venture capitalists.
We have billions of dollars. We have
trillions of dollars and we want to
invest in a company. Okay? So we're
approached by two companies.
We're approached by two companies.
Company A, company B. Okay?
So, company A comes to us and says that
look, I have 100 companies
and they're all profitable.
Okay, I don't have a business plan, but
I have lots and lots of resources and
have a lot of experience and a lot of
skill and so if I were to invest in
another company, I'm sure it'll make a
lot of money.
Okay.
All right. So skills and experience that
is company A.
Company B is
these young guys
and they failed. Okay, but they're like,
you know what? We're going to put our
heart and soul into this enterprise.
We're going to work 16 hours a day every
day for as long as it takes and we won't
stop. Okay? Even if this company is
successful, we're going to keep on going
because it's our passion. And if this
company fails, then we're bankrupt. We
might kill ourselves.
All right? So, if you are the venture
capitalist, do you put your money in A
or you put your money in B? Now, most
people would put their money in A
because they think it is low risk.
But if you're a smart man, you put your
money in B because it's high reward.
Okay, so company A already has 100
companies that are successful. People in
the company don't really care if there's
new enterprise is successful or not. Who
cares, right? I can afford to lose. In
which case, it's more likely the company
A steals your money and actually invest
it properly. Whereas company B is going
to be opposite where this is their last
chance. If they take your money, they're
going to make sure that they grow it
because if they don't grow it, then they
themselves die. Okay? So, you need um
these things. You need unity, capacity,
and determination.
Do you understand? And so, it what what
Israel is doing really is basically
auditioning to the world. We are ready
to replace America. We are ready to be
the new empire. Okay. All right. So,
let's look at what's happening. Um,
America has this MI mic. And so, the
MIC, military industrial complex, what
they're good at doing is producing very
expensive weapon systems. But
unfortunately, when you actually put
these weapon systems into war, doesn't
really do anything. Okay. So, this is
the Patriot missile system that's
supposed to that's supposed to protect
the GCC in Israel and American military
bases from uh Iranian drones and
missiles. Guess what, guys? Doesn't
really work. Okay, in fact, as you can
see from the video, the Iranians can
basically fly drones anywhere in the
Middle East. Americans can't really stop
them. All right, so this is billions of
dollars. Doesn't really do anything.
This is called the F35.
The F-35 is the most advanced fighter
jet in the whole world. It has stealth
technology, meaning you can't actually
lock onto it using radar.
This cost $100 million each. Take took
26 years to develop. So you would think,
wow, it took 26 years, so this must be
really, really good. No, it took 26
years because the MIC is really corrupt
and they want to steal as much money as
possible. Okay? And in this war, the
Iranians have already shot down at least
one of these jets. Okay, this is not
supposed to happen. You're not supposed
to be able to shoot these things down.
But have shot it down using very low
radar. Again, these things, they're not
designed to win wars. They're designed
to steal as much money as possible from
American taxpayer. Okay. Now, last
example is the Gerald Ford. This ship
cost $13 billion.
It cost $13 billion. The annual defense
budget for the Iranians is $10 billion.
It goes into the war theater and 3 weeks
afterwards it has to run away. Okay. And
in fact the Americans say, "Oh, the
Gerald Ford, this is the most advanced
supercure in the world. It's probably
going to be uh down for repairs in the
next 2 years." And there's argument as
to what happened. Okay, there are three
different possibilities. The first
possibility is that um there's a
accident in the laundry room and there's
a fire and this fire spread throughout
the carrier. Okay, which means that
actually the carrier is not very
resilient. Okay, so that's one
possibility and that's what the official
story is. But there are also others who
say like the Iranians hit the ship with
a missile and so the 04 can't protect
itself from Iranian missile so it ran
away. Okay. The third possibility, the
third explanation is the Pentagon
recognized that there are severe
limitations
of the 04 in actual combat operations.
Um its radar, its guidance system are
all very limited. So the Pentagon
withdrew the Gerald Ford because it was
absolutely useless in war, right?
Whichever story is true, it doesn't
paint a good picture of American
military. $13 billion
and this does nothing. Okay, it's just a
white elephant.
The Iranians are and also
um this is Ioima and this came
in World War II in the Pacific theater
when the Americans were fighting the
Japanese and this is the height of
American military glory. Okay. It took
about 6,000.
Americans lost 6,000 Marines in ticking
this island.
And that's a sacrifice you need in order
to win wars. You're going to lose a lot
of soldiers. And Americans are proud
that um they were willing to make a
sacrifice necessary to win the war. The
problem is Americans are not going to
win to sustain casualties. Okay. So, the
Americans send about 5,000 around 5,000
Marines to
um Iran hoping that 5,000 Marines will
be enough to win this war. Okay? But it
just shows you the Americans have no
strategy to win this war and they want
they don't want to want to make the
necessary sacrifices to win this war.
They want to win this war as quickly and
as cheaply as possible. Okay, the Isra
the Israelis are different. Okay, this
is Gaza and we all know that what Gaza
did was terrible. But again, if you are
auditioning to an empire,
Gaza is proof of concept, okay? Meaning,
it's showing the global elite, look,
we're willing to do what it takes to win
this war and defend the empire.
Okay? So this was a tremendous tragedy
and this and that's all war crimes.
Okay. And the entire world is a gas. But
if you look at Israeli public opinion,
82%
support expelling all Palestinians from
Gaza. Okay. 66% believe AMLAC exists
today. AMLAC is just like Israel has
this great enemy that they must defeat.
Right. So 66% of Israelis believe that
this war against Gaza is is a war for
the very existence of Israel. Okay, this
is unity.
This is determination.
The Americans don't have this. Most
Americans oppose what Israel is doing in
Gaza, but what Israel But is themselves
support what's going on. Okay. So
there's unity. All right.
All right. So um
in 2024 there was the famous Lebanon
pager attack. Okay, meaning that um the
Israelis were able to implant bombs into
pagers that went to Hezbala members and
then it blew up. Okay. And maybe
um from a military perspective it didn't
accomplish that much from a psych but
from a psych psychological perspective
it accomplished a lot. Okay. It scared
the living hell out of Hezbollah. It
made them paranoid and also made the
world respect Israel more. And Israel
spent $275 million
to uh conduct this operation that took
decades to implement. Okay.
And you're like, "Okay, why is telling
us this?" Because again, Israel is
auditioning to be the new empire. It's
telling the global elite, "Look, not
only will we fight this war for you, not
only will we be your muscle, but we'll
do it cheaply, man. Not billions of
dollars, millions of dollars."
Um,
this is ISIS.
ISIS Islamic State. Okay? And this is
considered a terrorist organization,
these Sunni uh extremists who go around
and beheading people. All right. Now,
this is from the New York Times. And the
yellow tells you areas in which they
operate. And as you can see, it's really
across the Middle East. And the red are
um incidents of attacks directed by
ISIS. Okay. Now, something that's really
funny about all this is ISIS attacks
everywhere in the Middle East except for
one country, and that country is
Israel. Okay? Really funny how you have
these Muslim extremists going around
committing all sorts of atrocities
everywhere in the Middle East except
Israel.
And so, that's why a lot of people
believe that Islamic State is actually
creation of Mossad.
But again
is happy for the world to know this
because again ishs auditioning to be the
new empire. And what issue is saying is
we don't have to use the American
strategy of just bombing everyone to
death. Okay, that's expensive. That's
brutal. It's not very strategic. We can
use MSA to infiltrate groups and use
these groups against the comrades, their
neighbors. is that much more efficient.
It's not much more effective. Okay. So,
what uh Israel is saying is we are much
better at controlling the Middle East
than the Americans. So, let us control
the Middle East using our strategies.
Okay. Um this is a story of a MSAD agent
who was disguised as an ISIS preacher.
Okay. And this happens a lot. There are
lots of stories where you have these
ISIS commanders or agents and they and
when you arrest them you discover, okay,
actually they're actually MSAD. Okay, so
ISIS is is basically a MSAD operation.
All right, so the main story here is
okay, if you look at history, the
relationship between Israel and America
is actually pretty simple. Israel
is the pitbull
for America.
The problem with an empire as it grows
old is it doesn't want to do bad things.
Okay? It wants to feel good about
itself. Therefore, it subcontracts the
violence, the murder, the genocide to
different people, okay? To mercenaries,
the Israelis in um the Middle East. And
this is a pattern throughout human
history. So the Romans started out as
mercenaries for the atrishians in Italy.
The Aztecs started out as mercenaries
for the Kolkakan in Mexico. The Greeks
started out as mercenaries for the
Persians. Okay. The started out as
mercenaries for the Chinese. The Aadian
started out as mercenaries for the
Samrians. The Mik Mo started out as
mercenaries for the Aud dynasty in
Egypt. In every instance, what happened
is the mercenaries eventually got to a
point where we are the ones killing
ourselves for this empire. The empire is
corrupt, decadent, and weak. Why don't
we just take it over?
And they did. Okay, we're seeing a
similar situation play out today in the
Middle East where Israel was created by
the British and Americans to be the to
be their pitbull, to be their uh
aircraft carrier in the Middle East to
create as much instability as possible
so that the Americans and the British
can control their oil supply in the
Middle East. And this has gone on for
decades and now the Israelis are like,
"Wait a minute here. We're the ones
doing all the work. We're the ones
making all the sacrifices. We're the
ones that are getting all the hate in
this world. So why shouldn't we be the
empire now? America's useless.
Okay. All right. So this is a pattern
throughout human
history. And
so we're going to look at what this
means. Okay. So Israel has something
called the greater Israel project.
And this is what
um extremists in Israel believe. They
believe that God in the Bible promised
the entire Middle East to the
uh Jewish people. Okay? Extending from
the Nile in Egypt all the way to the
Euphrates
in
uh Iraq. Okay? And it also encompasses
Saudi Arabia, Jordan, Lebanon, Syria,
and parts of of Tur Turkey as well.
Okay. Now, something really funny about
this map is this.
Iran, Persia
is not part of the Greater Israel
Project. So then you're ask yourself,
wait a minute here. If Iran is actually
not part of the Greater Israel project,
then why is Israel going to war with
Iran? Well, the reason why is if they
want all this territory, their main
enemy is not Syria that's been
destroyed. It's not Iraq that's been
destroyed. It's not Saudi Arabia, it's
too weak. Not Jordan, it's too weak. Not
Egypt, it's too weak. Not Lebanon. It's
not It's too weak. Okay. Their main
enemy is the American Empire. Okay. In
the Greater Israel project, the m it's
the Americans that control the land of
greater Israel, the Middle East. These
are American bases. So, in other words,
you use this war against Iran to destroy
the American Empire. How? By forcing the
American Empire to go and invade Iran.
And when this happens, America will be
too overextended.
and then they'll be forced to retreat
from the Middle East. Okay? And so, um,
eventually America will be defeated.
America will be forced to retreat from
the Middle East. And I believe two
regional powers, okay? Iran and Israel.
And again, because of the Greater Israel
Project, the Israelis have no problem
with this. Persia is again not part of
the Greater Israel Project. The Israelis
don't really care if Iran is still
standing. They want Iran to be um as
weaken as possible, okay? But they
really don't care. They really don't
need to defeat Iran to achieve the
biblical prophecy, but they do need to
defeat the Americans. All right? The
Americans are in the way. All right.
Okay. So, what does the Greater Israel
Project mean? Well, it means control of
the world's oil. Basically 20% of the
world's oil. So these are the gas
fields. The yellow are the gas fields of
the Middle East. All right? And the blue
are the trade routes. So you can see how
Israel is at the very center of all this
wealth, right? They have the logistics,
they have the technology. it makes sense
for them to take control of all these
resources and then start shipping these
resources to Europe as well as to East
Asia, China, South Korea and Japan.
Okay, so that's what the Paka will look
like. It will be a trade network
controlling all the resources um of the
Middle East and then shipping off to the
rest of the world.
All right.
Then you have data centers. Okay. So,
Israel has the most data centers in the
Middle East and then start has 36. Uh,
UA has 34. Okay. So, these three places
are competing um against each other for
AI dominance.
Why is AI important? Because it allows
you to create a surveillance state.
Surveillance is is what you need for an
empire, right? Right? You need to
control the population. All right? Now,
the problem with Saudi Arabia and UAE is
for them to build their data centers,
they need to import
foreign expertise. They themselves do
not have the human capital to build
these data centers and to run these data
centers. On the other hand, Israel does.
Okay. Israel has the best universities
in the Middle East. It has the best IT
talent in the Middle East. It has it has
the best human capital. Therefore, it
makes perfect sense for Israel to just
absorb the entire AI network of the
Middle East and become the main
epicenter of AI surveillance in the
Middle East. Okay, which will become the
backbone of Pakista.
One more. Um,
so what does Pak Juda look like? It's
really the India Middle East trade
corridor. Okay.
All right. So look look at this map
where um for India to get to Europe it
has to go through
Israel.
Okay. So this is what pass Judica will
look like. Basically a theback trade
corridor that that will um unite the sub
Asian continent with Europe. Okay. But
not only that, but the idea of this is
also to connect to Africa,
right? Because no other place is able to
access Africa. Only Israel is. And not
only that, but it's also able to access
Ukraine and Russia.
So the idea is to take Russian and
Ukraine energy and food and then
transport it into Africa that's
combining the world. Okay. So Israel
because of its location can really be
the epicenter of all global trade.
All right. Now let's look at um Iran.
So for the longest time, Iran did have
lots of resources, oil, oil resources,
but the Americans put sanctions
on this these oil exports. This war has
basically lifted all sanctions. Okay. So
the Iranian economy is now able to
export its oil all across the world. So
this is uh treaty parsing and he is
probably America's foremost expert on
Iran and he talks to a lot of people and
what he's saying is basically
um Iran now is able to produce oil,
transport it across the world and then
um get money for it. Okay.
So what the conclusion he makes is this.
Trump and Israel's war has ended up
delivering Iran def facto sanctions
relief.
Before the war, Iran was cut off from
the global economy. Because of this war,
Iran now is becoming embedded into the
global economy. It's the complete
opposite of the intention of this war.
And what this means is Iran is now less
incentivized to end the war. Okay. The
more this war keeps on going, the more
Iran benefits economically.
All right. So Iran once this war ends
becomes the epicenter of two major trade
networks. Okay. Okay. The first is
something called the north south
transport corridor that links Russia.
Okay. Um and
and Iran together. Okay. And this will
then allow Russia to access India and
Asia and allow Iran to access Europe.
Okay. So this is the north south quarter
that's controlled by Russia. But also
you have of course the belt and road
initiative and guess what terrain
is also at the epicenter of this trade
network. Okay. So for China access
Europe it has to go through Iran. For
Europe to access China it has to go
through as well. Okay. So this is what
the new world will look like after the
war. You'll have two regional powers,
Israel and Iran. And they will have
their own independent trade networks
and they will have their own access to
um resources. So uh Israel will control
the resources of the Middle East and
Iran will control the hummus. Okay. And
with the to think like a toll which will
feed the economy they will be helped by
Russia and China because it is in Russia
and China's best interest develop the
infrastructure of Iran to facilitate
global trade. Okay. But then you're like
wait a minute here but Iran and Israel
are enemies.
Okay. So this is a misunderstanding.
Ideologically
Iran and Israel are enemies. But I want
to teach you three basic principles or
rules of geopolitics. Okay? And once you
understand these rules, it'll be much
easier for you to understand the new
world that we're going into. The first
is this.
The strong respect each other and pray
on the weak. Okay, this makes sense,
right? Why are the strong fighting each
other? Wouldn't it be easier for them to
like leave each other alone and go pick
on the weak? It benefits everyone,
right? So, in this situation, right, you
have four, you have um different
countries. You have GCC, you have um
Israel, you have the United States, you
have um Iran. Okay. So, you have these
four different players in this war.
Right now it's essentially um Israel,
GCC and US fighting against Iran.
But if
Iran proves it is strong
and Israel proves it's strong
and GC proves it's weak, the US proves
it's weak. Guess what's going to happen?
Is are going to get together and say,
"SCREW THESE GUYS.
LET'S work together, man. Okay. Does
that make sense? Even though at in the
beginning it seems as though um Israel,
GCC and US are allies against Iran,
ultimately if it if Iran is able to
prove it's strong,
then Israel will ban the GCC in the
United States
and Israel will work with Iran to build
a new order in the Middle East because
that's a law of the jungle. Okay, that
is what is in the best interest
according to game theory for Israel.
And the last thing to understand is the
weak do not work well together. The weak
must ally with the strong for
protection. Okay? So what this means is
that GCC is weak. Right? So you look at
Saudi Arabia,
UAE,
uh, Bahan,
Oman,
Kuwait,
Qatar. Okay, so these are the six GCC
countries. They're all weak. And you
would think, you know what, if they were
to combine their resources and fight
together, they could probably beat
Israel or probably beat Iran. The
problem with this is weak players don't
work well together. Okay? They're weak
because they're stupid. They are. And so
what they do is rather than seek to work
together, what they do is they seek to
ally with stronger forces. Okay? So
right now they're they're all aligned
with the United States and Israel.
All right. Against Iran. But as this war
progresses and the US falls, then what
will happen is that they must either
choose Israel or Iran.
And what's going to happen is that you
might have some places Qatar and Oman
who choose, you know what, screw this,
we're going to join Iran. And you have
Saudi Arabia and UAE who are like, okay,
let's join Israel. Okay.
But the GCC, regardless of what happens,
will no longer be a major global factor
in the Middle East anymore. A lot of
them will be destroyed because of this
war. All right? So, according to game
theory, this is what the world should
look like after the war ends. But again,
this is all theory. Okay? This is a
class focused on intellectual
speculation. It's meant to be fun. It's
meant to to make us more curious about
the world. It's supposed to heighten our
critical thinking skills. This is not
meant to be prophecy. Okay? I'm not
saying this must happen. I'm saying this
might happen for these reasons. And if
they do happen because
they do happen, then this provides us a
good framework to understand our
reasoning better. Okay? If it doesn't
work out this way, it's fine because
we'll just go back and analyze what what
went wrong better. Okay. What's really
important is not to set a judgment.
What's really important is keep our
minds open and be open to the
possibility of um different outcomes.
All right. Okay. Any questions, guys?
>> Um if Israel really like defeated
America, what will
>> No, no, no, no. I didn't say Israel will
defeat America. I never said that. Okay.
Well, Israel might
>> No, no, no. Let's be clear about
language. I did not say Israel will
fight America. What I said is Israel is
auditioning to replace America. Israel
is trying to prove to global elite I'm
strong enough to replace America when
America leaves the Middle East. You
understand?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Let's be clear about language.
Okay. Yes.
like um what will like Israel try to
prove that it's stronger than America
and I'm curious like what the next step
Israel will take if like it's trying to
show that it's strong.
Okay.
All right.
So
look,
Israel doesn't have to do anything
different. Israel is determined to win
this war, right? That's all it has to
do. Israel's determined to win this war
and the United States is not determined
to win this war. The doesn't even know
what it's doing. Okay. All right. So
what's important? Okay. What's really
important is to go back to our analysis
of H. Sorry, not yet. Yeah. like um this
is all right.
Okay, let's draw our analysis. Okay,
remember you need an empire.
You need an empire. Okay.
And you have the finance, the game
masters, and then you have um the global
economy. Okay. All right. to these
different players. And again, there's a
really important idea to understand. All
these players are interested in
maintaining a status quo.
Eventually, as this war progresses,
they're going to recognize that America
is actually a problem. The American
Empire is not a good thing. It's not a
benefit to us. It's a it's a problem for
us. And so, we need to replace the
American Empire, right? And who's the
only alternative? Israel. So we need to
transition from
America to Israel if we are to maintain
a system. Then they recognize that okay
the problem though is America will not
go away.
Empires don't surrender power willingly.
And so we need to create a situation
which America is forced out of the
Middle East. Now Iran cannot defeat
America on the battlefield. America can
drag this thing on for at least 20
years. But we we don't want to wait 20
years because we'll lose a lot of money
in the process and there's no point in
waiting 20 years. So we need to force
America out of the Middle East. So if we
cannot if we cannot defeat America sorry
if Iran cannot defeat America on the
battlefield what we need to do is cause
America to implode. We need to cause a
collapse in America. And how do you do
that? The economy.
If I crash the stock market, if I cause
oil to go way up,
if I cause a discontent in America, this
will cause a civil war in America. And
then the American military has no choice
but to retreat back into America. Okay?
And then Israel will naturally take over
from America.
And this is something we'll discuss next
class. Okay? The strategy for how to
destroy the American Empire and replace
it with Israel.
Right. Okay. Does that make sense? Okay.
Any more questions, guys?
>> Okay, great. So, I will see you next
week.